dink is an acronym that stands for dual
income no kids so these are the
childless by choice folks uh those who
get married and could have kids but
choose instead to have a Barren sterile
relationship focused entirely on their
own superficial wants and desires there
are variations on the dink or the sync
single income no kids you could be a
dink wad which means double income no
kids with a dog dink wads who previously
spoke to Business Insider said that the
lifestyle gives them Financial stability
the capacity to travel and the ability
to dodge the ever increasing cost of
Parenthood yes dink wad if you have a
dog or I guess dink whack if you have a
cat or dink if you own a pony or a
pig or a parrot or if you're a big cardi
B fan I said Certified Freak seven days
a week wet ass Pew word